when kevin you've you've never been in a
film together no no no no no
no no
no no no no
no but the plan is you'd like to yes we
are trying like we're you know we're
both from philly too so it's like we
love to work together we've been looking
at a few you know a few things but uh
kevin stays really busy and it's uh it's
hard to fit into his schedule so that's
you know i think that the beauty of the
idea of us working together is is such a
wonderful thing that we just want to
make sure it's right it's right yeah we
want to make sure like we don't want to
just throw something together we feel
that when that moment happens it should
be something that people hold on to and
really gravitate towards and understand
how special of a moment it is yeah you
know we could do wawa west too
oh
[Applause]
if you did work together i mean the
world would go crazy yeah but
philadelphia might explode oh my god yes
when you go back to philadelphia
presumably you visit this oh yeah this
is a 65-foot mural yeah of will smith
right
but someone else has a mural in
philadelphia who well to show it well
it's only
[Applause]
except kevin kevin though you do have
one up on will because that's a special
day that is that is that is a special
day for me um i have a day in
philadelphia but that's uh that's max's
and it's uh it's a place where i
frequented to get cheese steaks do much
you have a day
a kevin hart day philadelphia county
heart day yeah it's just philadelphia if
you have a christmas day no no no no
no i have a little smooth time for you
yeah no that's that's all that's what
i'm thinking is
[Applause]
uh march march 21st wow do you go back
every year no i send a card
yeah
you're working together in a latin we'll
talk about that but um octavia you have
also worked with will i don't know if
you all remember this uh and and it was
a session right yeah there's a special
moment yeah on will's birthday i think
either this year or last year i wrote
about what you did for me i'm probably
going to cry
oh my gosh we were working on seven
pounds and i was only on that movie for
three days will pulled in as i was
coming out of my trailer which was a
honey wagon
i mean i was whiter than a name
and i was coming out i was going to hair
and makeup the very next day i go to my
trailer and they said oh you've been
moved and i had been put into like this
triple banger which you never get
anything that's not in your contract and
the a.d told me that will had changed my
dream upgraded my trailer wow
triple banger though
it's better ones than the triple back
[Applause]
probably put you in a the quadruple bag
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but are they will was sort of part of
your life before this film i don't know
if you know this is true yeah he was a
part of my life um via my brother who is
the biggest will smith fan and i feel
like people say that they're like yeah
i'm the biggest will smith fan like my
brother knows those like deep cuts of
your album do you know what he is he
knows the stuff i don't know
he is obsessed yeah but like to the
point where you've sent us a picture i
don't know if you know you've sent us a
picture of his bedroom this is your
brother's bedroom
that was there that was there before you
got the allowance oh yeah no no no no no
before this is like our at our family
home and i would walk
wait he's like let me tell you you ain't
16 people all right
how do you see it where are you going
where's he where's his mother
where is
[Music]
that picture it seems unlikely that josh
is married but he is
he is and and
he sent us this picture this is from the
actual first dance at the wedding
you're there
his first dance was getting jiggy with
it was your first dance
all right i just want to backfill up beg
your kids
it's a
serious morning
oh
[Applause]
[Music]